what's going on there citizens of the
reject nation we're gonna watch cobra
kai season five episode seven today
andrew got us these shirts andrew hooray
for andrew our easter egg reference boy
in the house follow him movie source
channel acor 7-eleven haven't mentioned
that at all in any of the intros now i
am because i'm a good person and uh
leave a like for andrew also subscribe
click the notification bell for andrew
and following throughout your watch long
so you can seek up the time code to
watch this show with andrew over at our
patreon page for super sexy rejects
lastly prepper thanks for helping us
head it down andrew's reactions
all right guys let's get to
[Music]
it side with cobra kai
grand opening of our new location you
should come check it out
we'll feel the pain
oh no
oh right right place right time
old school
there's the dookie in there oh no
oh
[Music]
i'm glad they didn't show that is messed
up
oh there is
someone who may know
someone who knows silver best
don't even say it to beat a monster
maybe we need a monster release the
kraken the enemy of your enemy is your
friend
line up
chosen training that's awesome
where are my dad and johnny not here
[Laughter]
from
begin your preparation what are we
protecting them from
from me
ah wowie
what exactly is the game here
i'm gonna attack you and don't smash
this egg
give them some real competition
the leaders will rise
or they will crumble
oh i like that
yeah
that's a good line you should say that
on the show
if anyone knows what silver's up to it's
crease
hopefully this place has taken him down
a few pegs
hey so can i uh get your soda or
something maybe something from the
vending machine
[Music]
yes sorry sensei
[Laughter]
hey
deja vu having you back here
i like what you done with the place i
mean how many times does your dad make
you sand that sparring deck zero
actually is your dad brought a power
sander
look at him trying to move in on her
dude if you want me to i'll kick you
guys
no you don't need to do that
robin and i are cool now besides i'm
pretty sure they're just uh
catching up
don't be a miguel
i made it out of my college prep book
for blunt force impact and i tied the
whole thing together with an old spool
of dental floss and
my left shoe lace
yep
it's pretty durable
[Music]
[Laughter]
you're gonna go to the right you swing
when i tell you okay
sweet go go go
just listen to me man okay i got your
back but you got to get in there
okay go low
aprices
i mean he could hear the plan
yeah
fighting stunts
goddamn
listen
you want to work together
[Music]
i'm here because terry was tight with
the d.a and i couldn't afford a realtor
oh please
what if i could help get you out
silver isn't the only one with resources
i can get a lawyer someone who can help
get you out or my cousin vinnie
that's awesome
but i want a top guy not one of your
greasy cousins hold on you're gonna help
him get out of here johnny greasy cousin
it's worth the sacrifice
it's the only way i could call my lawyer
right now
right now please be joe bashi i would
love to hear this
so would i
oh god come on please don't
hmm
[Music]
you want my egg huh
you want a piece of the champ i can get
it old man oh
my god
[Music]
can't believe you gave up anybody knows
how kubrick i can turn you to an [ __ ]
it's you oh so i'm an [ __ ] yeah well
let's see uh you attacked me and sam at
the mall you you broke dimitri's arm you
you trashed this entire dojo guys enough
enough all right you're both ex-assholes
now
you know we have so many other things
going on and there's no need for extra
complications
and honestly i think us not being
together actually helped robbie and i
get along for once so
thanks
i'm really glad to hear that yeah
oh no
you want the last egg you're gonna have
to go through me
how many times have you cleaned your
hands
[Laughter]
you want to do everything already all
you've been doing is sending me in and
get pulverized
i'm done being a punching bag
i spent a lot of my life listening to
others
but it was only after i listened to my
own instincts that i reached my
potential
you said kylo was the leader
did i
why did you assume that
mind blown
he's willing to help you out
is his number
but first you gotta hold up your end
tell us what silver's up to
okay
he's gonna make a fart noise
but what if we weren't a bunch of once
uh you know you know like what if we
were
together yeah exactly like um like a
writing party in dungeon lord yeah yeah
i i mean even if you're a level 85 you
can't mount an attack on the grand realm
alone exactly exactly now you're
speaking my language
as if we work together
as one
[Music]
combine our eggs
master egg
put all our eggs in one basket
i mean you're specifically not supposed
to do that
oh no oh no oh god get it together penis
breath oh god oh man he's gonna have a
bow and arrow
oh
this is exciting
they work together
[Music]
don't give up chosen
[Music]
do a flip
snake
conceit
[Applause]
you would not last one minute in my
dojang back home
fighting stunts
lights
but tori's like an undercover cop now
if you had sacrificed your porn you
might have scored that point there are
no points in the real world
but there are in this exercise
so you lose
you're moving the goalposts i'd call you
mommy
a new strategy perhaps oh no sensei i
might need a new follower we'll see for
ourselves lana
all right
take him down kenny
just follow me
what do you say
we need a change in leadership
you could do better yeah watch me
oh yeah
oh damn kenny you better not
oh
[Applause]
dang
and he paid for a trip for us to go back
east
to where the way of the fist first
started
so he could learn from the source
himself
master kim son young
[Music]
terry silver yeah let's do it
actors from the flashbacks
lack of consistency
sorry master kim my fault i'll see
see chris was a nice one yeah he's good
cop
i'll still pay rent
don't think
cobra kai is the best dojo in the valley
but you can do better than the valley
remember the first time you told me
about the old valley
i'm about to do you one better all
planet the sekai thai guy
the top karate tournament in the world
but we aren't ready
maybe one day we will be but right now i
need to focus on my students there's
this new kid
i got a feeling about terry i think that
he could be our best ever johnny
lawrence
even has the same name as me
his name is john creason
but if you change your mind
need help
i'll be here for
you cobra kai
never dies
silver's going to enter cobra kai in
another tournament not just another
tournament
the biggest tournament in the world of
course
many wins
global viral
it's like a resident evil movie now
but you are outmatched
and outnumbered
the lawyer's number
he's gonna make mince meat out of you
we'll see about that
enjoy riding in yourself
so many efforts this season i know
it's not for kids anymore's karate men
there goes our joe pesci cameo
yeah but you could hear it in joe
pesci's voice
yeah yeah you can't utes i can't wait
till cobra kai season 10. skylak
when everything is an apocalyptic
landscape
overcast is dominating everywhere
there's actual cobras it's slithering
all over the world 10 years into the
reign of cobra kai
we lost most major cities by five years
in now there's no running water no power
people just fight to survive
what's hilarious about this show is
um
they're not that great at martial arts
[Laughter]
like most of them aren't that great
so it's just funny in the context when
you step out of it like i buy into it in
my experience of viewing it but it's
just funny when you're like
yeah but like you know there are people
who are definitely much better martial
artists out there obviously like what
they're talking about
the greatest tournament in the world i
know they're going to subdue
the other opponent's
ability like so you guess what i mean
come on let's face it they're going to
know their form is not the greatest they
look like they have a hard time kicking
a lot of the time
definitely actors who are trained so
yeah william's up cooking kind of
yeah yeah no definitely no no no there's
like uh that 1980s action hero like
billy jack yeah that's what they all are
they're all a bunch of billy jacks in a
world that exists of donnie yen's
that's what i want to say i want to see
oh uh johnny versus it man
yeah that'd be nice
all right
all right clowns clowns andrew yes take
it away all right
thank you
oh i'm sorry i'm sorry
that was did you get that at jaby kawas
like really stuck on it um all right so
really quick uh only a few easter eggs
and references that i noticed the first
one was when anthony got the swirly at
the beginning in season three when they
had the committee to get rid of the all
valley tournament they made mention of
swirlies which johnny pointed out to the
committee what a swirly was we finally
got to see one
literally in person uh the other one
that i noticed was uh we saw the
the granddaughter of kim sun young when
she said that uh pain does not exist we
got that line from sensei john crease
and the first karate kid when he said
payton does not exist in this dojo we
did get that also a few times in earlier
seasons of cobra kai uh we also got when
johnny and daniel visit the prison to
see crease it kind of reminded me to
reference wise to season i believe it
was season three when they're looking
for robbie when he's gone on the run
after what he did to miguel they go
looking for robbie's old friends the bad
kids uh one who looks like chris brown
and uh the other kid i forgot what their
names were but they're reminding me of
all the seasons of prison break too oh
good catch good catch and then obviously
shawshank redemption
greg saw that check out that reaction
was great
yeah exactly anyways
the other one greg pointed out uh where
he says uh i don't want your your greasy
cousin obviously that was a reference to
my cousin vinnie 1992 jonathan john said
ah
at that not me
has already said the vinnie thing yeah i
tried to give you i tried to give you
some beautiful
reference though i tried to give you
credit all right fine john good job and
danny also has two cousins in the
context of the show's also italian
[Music]
coming after me this episode uh anyways
those were the easter eggs design
those were the easter eggs and
references i noticed uh this episode was
really uh good it was definitely a a
little bit different than the last
episode with how heavy emotionally the
last one was but uh some things that i
really enjoyed i love seeing the
different dichotomy of the training of
uh what we got from chosen obviously
he's much different with how he trains
miyagi fang versus what johnny how
johnny trains his dojo and versus how
danny i think they pointed out best like
he's kind of like the tougher version of
both of them mixed into one uh which was
very appropriately said because that's
how i felt in the moment while watching
him but i really enjoyed watching
the way he influences his students
because we only got a little bit uh
pointed out of that in season three when
daniel went to okinawa to visit chosen
we were told that he trains classes and
we also saw in karate kid part two we
saw that little moment where daniel was
looking through the dojo and we saw
chosen training and beating the crap out
of some students so glad we got to
actually get some dialogue and got to
see uh actually how he does train his
students so i was really cool to see
that i also like seeing two
uh the uh
uh
what's kim sung young's granddaughter i
like seeing her as well trent with her
training her students uh just how
ruthless she can be
and it was just again just the dichotomy
of how different they are with training
their dojos it's really interesting to
watch and then again watching terry
silver just get into the head of kenny
like hey i didn't tell you not to be a
leader like you assume that just again
he just really knows how to manipulate
people get into their heads whether it's
for good or for bad purposes i just
enjoy watching it and i am such a sucker
for the flashbacks of terry silver and
john crees those are some of my favorite
moments ever because that relationship
is one of my favorite parts of karate
kid part three granted i know martin
kova john crease was not in karate kid
part three for very much of the film
having said that i love those two
together and their flashbacks it just
adds to a level of depth to their
relationship and just seeing it fleshed
out more it just i really love those
moments and just seeing them actually
because we got again we we've talked
about this a few times this season just
hearing
and that moment we got in karate kid
part three where terry silver said that
he was trained by master uh sensei kim
sung young in south korea and then
getting a little moment we didn't get a
lot of it but just seeing it was really
cool to watch and then seeing the
granddaughter again i love when we get
stuff flushed out like that it just
again it just adds to the depth level of
that relationship and i loved every
second of it and i think also too that
suit that terry silver was wearing might
have been wearing that suit in karate
kid part three as well i just thought of
that
nicely done well done nicely done man
i agree
i agree with everything you said thank
you
i agree with everything you said about
me too i know i didn't say much either
all right guys
please let me take it away
just warming up
stretch get it get a stretch and
do some forms just to limber up going up
to the batter plate you know that's a
baseball reference
oh is that what that was yeah is that a
sport you're ready to strike out foul
ball i gotta learn about that sport
touchdown bro
i would like in what chosen is doing
to
300 versus the persian army
you know what i mean well i like it yeah
we will fight in the shade because it's
about
um it's not about the quantity it is
about how you guys work together as a
unit
that's how you can take on the masses
and that's why they won in the n300
they was i whooped all their ass
did they win i thought they got killed
andrew haven't you seen or read 300 or
the history that inspired it no i mean
my dvd stopped working like 20 minutes
it's predictable [ __ ] they're gonna win
that's a that's a real thing with that
dvd too
yeah part way through there are many
copies that are just messed up so and uh
yeah so king leonidas won in the end
okay yeah
release the snyder cut
so
yes where they lose
i
yeah i uh is not my uh favorite one of
the seasons so far but another good
installment uh
of the season
i think it's kind of been like every
episode's been on like an up like just
so upward for me yeah that there's
nothing bad about this one at all to me
it's just the impact is not as strong as
like how it's been escalatingly more
impactful every episode and this one was
like no it's a good one it it progresses
the story forward you get to learn it's
like a lot of information and setup of
what's to come you learn about the big
karate tournament the ultimate plan
which
it is all leading to a tournament
it's the world it's the world tournament
where uh yeah that that makes sense and
um
this is funny how like big of an
important of a tournament it is no one
in the states has heard of it
if it's important we will have heard
that it's the most big we are
2022. of course we have not important
things are our business the martial arts
community you put a person i don't even
like daniel theroux is like what is this
maybe the tournament overseas
um only the ultra rich know about
it it's a dark web tournament and uh
and and then you know kenny rising to
the occasion like i don't see any of
this rapping i don't see a lot of this
wrapping up this season i think i
believe they were greenlit for two
seasons
two more seasons which is why i think we
got this season so early
comparatively normally they come out in
january december and january december
january yes you want to be super
technical like december 31st sorry
december area um so yeah they released
they released all the
it's like this is coming out nine months
after the last season that's almost
unheard of in general with television
you know
um
so yeah they're coming out so i think
you know this is all setting up a lot
for
what might not ultimately get fully
resolved like i doubt they're going to
go to the major tournament at the end of
this season you know what i mean
but seeing what they're building i liked
how there's like multiple leaders
involved and i like the tease
of possibly johnny lawrence actually
taking back cobra kai to make it his own
like ooh i feel like they're planting a
very specific seed there to bring it
back full circle to oh he's doing his
own thing with cobra kai because i got
to keep kobrakai the name of life what
happens when they defeat cobra kai the
show's going to be eagle fang yeah
ten more seasons like they did what if
he does want to take back cobra kai
making his own a little bit more back to
the roots you know because john crease
doesn't seem like he was always an
[ __ ]
so
yeah no it's like uh i
i like the i do like the duality of the
training and watching miguel and sam
bond again
where he wants to [ __ ] himself and
be like it's good then we broke up good
thing we're not again a good thing yeah
it's a good thing it's all good thing
all good things man good things good
things i'm happy you're happy you're
happy i'm happy yeah i don't love you
anymore i don't like it you're ugly to
me bye wow i want you to go be with
robbie please yeah
go i'm gay
that's what i learned in mexico bye yeah
i'm gay bye
see how metrosexual my dad is and i was
like i gotta start over
john i left you plenty to talk about oh
totally yeah 100 it's very uh i'm a
little action oriented episode it was
well that's that's kenny that is the
thing yeah kenny i mean you know it was
nice i
i like kyler as a character because
kyler is the one constant never changes
and is unflappable in that no matter how
much of a dick he is when he's bossing
somebody around you put him in his place
and immediately he's like kenny i got
your bag for you man we're cool
um but yeah i mean you know we're
obviously mounting for some kind of new
in cobra kai sort of civil war-ish thing
because you've got
tori arcing out and you've got kenny
arching even further in
and you know they both got that linchpin
of robbie that you know is going to come
back around that fold somehow but yeah i
mean i i really like that detail of like
no no it's not that i said you should
follow kyler uh because thinking about
in the episode i think they sneak it
past you where you're like wait a minute
i don't remember him saying oh sure
enough he didn't say that so you just
assumed and i feel like that's you know
a great psychological test
or whatever but yeah like on the whole
this is one that that feels
more
action-oriented more place-set and and i
didn't feel like there was quite as much
of like a
a real
unified core theme but there were a lot
of interesting moments and scenes and
developments for sure across it i think
my favorite stuff was the the chosen
training
you know array of things that i'm
learning
yeah the idea that we should work
together and that being sort of a
breakthrough moment for anthony i
thought was nice and two i wonder what
the karmic payoff is going to be for uh
john uh johnny and danny because
as gratifying as it is in the moment and
as much as you don't want to be like
yeah let's help get chris out on the
streets i feel like that
that like harsh rebuke
could have some icky consequences down
the line or could still come with its
sort of price to pay
even for how much of like a flex it is
in the moment
yeah
part of you thought it was a little
messed up too because yeah it isn't uh
it's not honorable and yeah it's like
mystery i haven't done that i'm still
like
innocent
you have this of this at least like yeah
no matter what you disagree i feel like
these characters too as much as yeah
they have all their reasons to feel
the traumas and the the animosity
towards crease they do i also feel like
as much of a manipulator as crees can be
he also has a much more clear-cut
straightforward like attitude to where
uh yeah i don't know there's something
about it where i feel like you would
bring maybe an ounce of honor when you
talk to this guy or maybe use him as a
part of your plan versus doing something
that's going to actively kind of
repel him from you and now i'm like well
great is he going to be kind of a new
chaotic neutral player because this
can't be the last we've seen him in the
season but also i don't necessarily see
him just going back to terry so yeah
i'm curious as to what that could
develop into and as much as part of you
goes man if they could reconcile somehow
and then all three team up how crazy
would that be but i feel like the more
realistic outcome for that is just you
add this extra variable back in of
crease kind of has allegiance to nobody
in this fight there is no enemy of my
enemy anymore it's just he's got enemies
yeah i think for me
again just for me i think the theme of
this episode was leadership and working
together uh just you know we had
different different bonds of working
together we had yeah i was a [ __ ] about
that i was like
an emotional culture you had you had you
had right you had you had touring not
john's john's very smart you had tory
and devin working the other you had that
uh the relationship there and then you
had kenny and kyler the how different
that was and then also robbie and hawk
which i loved uh how they were working
together uh with you know there's a
tumultuous tumultuous relationship that
they have and they wanted you know they
hate each other so seeing them work
together was very it was very satisfying
very well done very well executed and
then also uh again the different styles
of leadership i just i love saying also
obviously we got danny and johnny
working together so it just it was
really different sprinkles of
interesting styles of teamwork and and
working together so i thought that it
was really handled well
sure
you're not stupid you're just dumb
there's a difference
there is
only a dumb person couldn't tell yeah
dumb's the one you're born with stupid
you can climb out of if you try hard
enough
no there's absolutely a theme of this
episode perhaps it was the wrong choice
of words i thought that the other
episodes had a good there's no
forgiveness wrong
emotional i love you
however the application of the leader
follow theme was very well handled
throughout because you see it on johnny
and danny talking to him
with chris and uh
terry silver in the past like that's a
very leadership move of crease to be
like hey those five people agree with
you for this idea that we should go do
this global tournament but you know what
i'm gonna go do my own thing that's a
real leadership move
i agree with you trying to tell him what
to or silver trying to tell him what to
do and then he pulled the total kenny
powers on him he was like you know what
i'm going to use you and i'm going to
jump over you and kick this guy in the
face john didn't want to have this
conversation but i don't think you
should join andrew and i for the next
episode
i think uh you're going to detract from
our experience i'm sorry
that's how it works here
only the strong survive yeah
you prove your worth here jaby just
brings on everyone
everyone any woman and the occasional
guy apparently apparently
and then next i will recruit you to my
team yes when you've been spurned i'm
going to project i'm going from cobra
kai to eagle thing to miyagi dill i'm
just going everywhere right
he's sick son of a [ __ ]
all right guys
um let's do a shout out i think you
should do a picture
lance door
lancy panty
lance is a boy you will never
sing it you know i'm mentioning that
we're looking for lance dictionary we
went on to urban dictionary and we're
gonna find out what you really are made
of what the definition of your essence
is lance
and apparently
lance is a boy you will never forget and
that's true because we've been talking
about you for so long yeah i never want
to stop talking about you lance is a boy
who struggles with life but you know
what you meet that struggle every day
with your fire gear he tries to be happy
but sometimes can't do it sometimes get
that happiness up but it's hard you
don't have to be happy all the time man
sometimes life is low sometimes life is
blue he likes to be alone but he has a
few friends who he loves to be with
including his lady and his
baby uh hey he's the ladies man and it's
good that you've settled down now you've
quelled that uh which makes his ex quite
jealous but you don't need to worry
about that lance you've got a life now
you've got set up you've got you've got
everything you could possibly want you
are a boy who will never forget
you're one of a kind lance you're
somebody who won't judge anybody for who
they are
and uh they will lance will stay by your
side for whatever you go through whether
that's a fire
or just a trip to jimmy dean's or jimmy
john what's that uh
tim hortons there you go that's a
canadian thing
you want a data lance but you're not
sure if he's ready for it that's why you
want to date him that's right you got to
check him out first see what the
situation is but you love lance by the
end of it and you always will and we
always will and we appreciate you for
always loving us right back man i feel
so supported by you thank you for being
you lance you're the bomb
[Music]